you've got a job offer and now you have
a choice negotiate or not if you decide
not to and your buddy who got the same
offer negotiates and gets a $7000
increase by the end of 30 years your
buddy will be making $100,000 more a
year than you think about that my
husband's a trained chef
you know the chef's don't have recipes
for all those sauces they know the
structure of a sauce and so regardless
of the ingredients they have they can
make a great sauce and that's what I
want for you I'm not going to give you a
recipe for a particular negotiation
rather what I want to do is give you the
structure of a negotiation so that you
can be successful regardless of what you
face I want to propose a new way of
thinking about negotiation and what
you're trying to achieve in that
negotiation and then what I want to do
is give you four steps to help you be
more effective in getting what you want
folks typically see negotiation is an
adversarial process and are
uncomfortable because they're concerned
that other folks will think of them as
too demanding too greedy not nice or
socially awkward what I want to do today
is get you to change the frame of how
you think about negotiation moving it
from an adversarial process to one that
is problem solving and problem solving
is collaborative I want to solve our
problem in a way that's good for you but
also gives me more of what it is I want
when we negotiate most of us view the
goal of a negotiation as to get an
agreement this is wrong the goal of a
negotiation is not to get a deal the
goal of a negotiation is to get a good
deal we need to be able to separate what
a good deal is from what a bad deal is
so that means we need at least three
pieces of information the first thing we
need to know is what is our alternative
what happens to us at this negotiation
fails what are we left with what's the
status quo or what alternatives exists
for us and the research is very clear he
or she with the better alternative does
better secondly we need to know what our
reservation price is what's the point at
which we are indifferent between saying
yes and invoking our alternative and
when you negotiate it's critical that
you understand where that reservation
price is because that's the point at
which you are indifferent we're a know
looks as good as a yes
and the third point which is really
important and one that people often
overlook is that not only do we have to
think about our alternative and our
reservation price we also need to think
about our aspiration what is an
optimistic assessment of what it is we
can achieve in this negotiation
so how do you get more of what you want
let me suggest that four steps will help
you the first step is to assess the
situation is this a situation where I
can have influence on the outcome to
change that outcome in a way that makes
me better off and I need to weigh the
potential benefits from negotiating with
the potential costs for negotiating and
will the benefits outweigh the costs the
second step is I need to prepare and
there are really two aspects of this
step number one I need to understand
what my interests are what I'm really
trying to achieve in this negotiation
and the second component is I need to
understand the interests and preferences
of my counterpart many of us may
understand what our interests are but
few of us actually understand at a deep
level what the preferences and interests
are of our counterparts third now comes
the ask engage with your counterpart
look at these disputed social situations
as opportunities to negotiate you have
information that your counterparts don't
have and this is what you bring to the
table if they knew all your information
if they knew your perspective they don't
need you because you have unique
information and because they have unique
information that's where the value is
created fourth you need to package now
what do I mean by that most of us when
we negotiate negotiate issue-by-issue
this is a really bad strategy because
when you negotiate issue-by-issue every
issue is adversarial you either win or
lose when your packaging issues you now
have the opportunity to trade among the
issues so think about proposing
solutions alternative solutions to your
counterpart
in packages and to help you out because
your counterpart will probably want to
negotiate issue-by-issue
think about using if-then language if I
give you this then I get that what
you're doing is you're yoking various
issues together into a package to get
more of what you want there are four
steps assess prepare ask package
to give you an example my Dean recently
sent me an email indicating that I would
have to be going from five courses a
year to six courses a year because he
had received information from the
Provost that we needed to be consistent
in the amount of contact hours and
course credit I was not happy about that
email so my response was I think I need
to talk to my Dean let's negotiate but
before I started the negotiation I
thought hard about why was he doing this
what was in his interest his interest
was probably to make sure the Provost
was happy what was my interest not to
move from five classes to six classes
and it turns out I teach two different
types of classes MBA electives and then
some specialty classes there are lots of
folks who teach MBA electives there very
few folks who teach specialty classes so
I thought I should focus on the
specialty classes so then I went for the
ask I set up a meeting and part of that
meeting was to verify the information
that I had gathered in my planning
session and it did turn out to be true
he was interested in making the Provost
happy so then came the proposal that
packaged our interests he said he wanted
consistency between contact hours and
credit so what he did is he changed the
credit to match the contact hours I
suggested why not change the contact
hours to match the credit because it
turns out that in my courses in my
specialty courses we always went over so
while they were three hours it was
common that we would go for three and a
half to four hours so let's make him for
our courses and keep me at five whether
than move me to six he said to me I
never even thought of that
and why didn't he it wasn't that weird
because he didn't have the information
that I had that my classes routinely ran
over
and so when I gave him that information
it created a solution that made him as
well off as he was and made me a whole
lot better by the way I was the only
faculty member to get an exception and
why did I get an exception because
everybody else had the same email for
two reasons one I decided to negotiate
and number two I provided him with a
solution that made us both better off so
what are the unique opportunities and
challenges that women face when they
negotiate let's start off with an
example that's pretty far away from what
most of us think about as negotiations
in 2006 the US Tennis opens Grand Slam
tournament got some new technology and
for the first time they were able to
replay the calls and so they allowed the
players to challenge the calls of the
referees now it turns out that over the
course of the entire tournament about
one-third of the challenged calls were
given to the player but interestingly if
you divide it up the number of
challenges by gender it turns out the
men challenged seventy-three calls while
the women challenged twenty eight now we
can come up with all sorts of stories
about why men's tennis is different from
women's tennis men's sentences faster
maybe the judges make more mistakes
maybe the judges are paying more
attention to the women maybe but three
times difference in the number of
challenges women are simply
uncomfortable with asking expectations
drive behavior if we expect to do poorly
we will behave in ways that ensure a
poor performance this was demonstrated
in a piece of research that I think is
very telling when women were told that
people who are like them negotiate
poorly
they did significantly worse in their
negotiation performance than their male
colleagues when they were told that
people like them negotiate well they did
significantly better than their male
colleagues expectations drive behavior
if you change your expectations you will
change your outcomes as women we need to
be very cognizant of three aspects of
negotiation why am i asking how am i
asking and for whom am I asking let's
first talk about why you are asking it
turns out that women are much more
effective in negotiations when they pair
their competence with a communal
orientation women need to demonstrate
their concern for the other so how will
my skills help you the organization my
employer my team to do better so let me
give you an example a colleague of mine
had gotten a wonderful job offer from an
East Coast University so she came to me
and said can you help me figure out how
to leverage this offer I really don't
want to move I said no problem we can do
this
so I said make an appointment with the
Dean and take the offer with you be very
clear Dean we have a problem
I love Stanford but I just received this
offer and it's an attractive offer I
need some help can you help me figure
out how to stay here she wasn't making a
demand she wasn't giving an ultimatum
she was saying can you help me
communal problem solving how are you
asking
male evaluators penalize female
negotiators in a single-issue
distributive negotiation when I ask for
more money in ways that they do not
penalize her male counterparts female
evaluators penalize both males and
females for asking for more why the
women were penalized was because they
were perceived as being too demanding
and not nice now note I said a single
issue they were negotiating issue by
issue so how can I help you with this
pool of resources that I need to do my
job more effectively to make you better
off and packaging communal packaging
next for whom are you asking it turns
out that if we distill the research and
negotiation we have two big findings
number one you're better off negotiating
for yourself if you're a man number two
if you're negotiating for me I am much
better off if you are a woman women
outperform men in representational
negotiations between 14 and 23 percent
this is huge so I use this all the time
when I negotiate I don't negotiate for
myself I negotiate for my husband my
four dogs my seven horses and my 14
chickens that's a lot of mouths to feed
and it works
a client came to me asking for one of
our top consultants who was busy working
on another project full-time so I wanted
to staff it with a different consultant
but the consultant that the client
wanted really wanted that project as
well so she came up with the idea what
if we hired a junior consultant to work
underneath her and give her the
opportunity to work on both projects
with that leverage it worked for the
client it made the consultant really
happy and it really solved my problem
before coming to business school for me
negotiation was about preparing to beat
a price or aim for a higher number now I
realized that preparation for a
negotiation is much more than that it's
about identifying the issues are
important to me but also the issues are
important to the other parties that I'm
interacting with and I think that allows
us to be much more creative and actually
solve the problem one of the most
important things you can do in preparing
for your compensation negotiation is to
do your research and find out your
market value sometimes people will go to
websites and enter in their current
field and title in order to find out
what their salary ranges but I find that
those websites aren't all that accurate
and they often compile an average salary
it's safe to assume that if you've
performed strongly and you're asking for
a raise you're above average one of the
other things you can do is to survey a
membership group or an association
either online or offline and ask those
members what their salary ranges you can
do so anonymously if that feels more
comfortable to you I worked for a
fortune 50 company I got the promotion
of my dreams best day of my life went
out to dinner with a mentor that night
to celebrate learned that I was getting
paid substantially less than my six male
counterparts he said you've got to go
back in there and renegotiate had a lot
of fear that I might lose that job
but I did showed up next morning and I
renegotiated the concern of my boss was
I was younger and had far less
experience than all my counterparts yet
I pointed out to him that his
expectation of me was
that I would make the same goals as my
six counterparts for equally as large
accounts we discussed it and he agreed
and at the end of the day I got the
raise that I really deserved when you're
considering negotiating you need to be
very honest with yourself how much are
you willing to pay to avoid the
discomfort of negotiating and if you
decide that you're going to negotiate
you need to be strategic in how you ask
and finally negotiation is an
interdependent process every bad deal
you have gotten you've agreed to so you
need to have the capacity to say no and
sometimes when you say no the other side
comes back and says don't go let's talk
how about this is it good for you but
you'll never know that unless you're
willing to walk away recently I had a
client enter negotiation where the terms
really didn't work for me and so I told
them it's just not economically rational
for me to take the deal and it kept it
objective and not personal which really
worked for me and allowed me to walk
away from the deal but keep the door
open when I got my first job I didn't
even negotiate for salary I had no idea
how to set a goal I had no idea how to
make the ask now it's a little bit
different I understand how to set an
aspirational goal and in that
preparation I get to the point where I
understand how it benefits all the
different parties that are involved but
you really do have to understand how you
feel in order to understand what it is
that you want because if you don't know
what you want you can't negotiate for it
earlier in my career I realized that the
types of projects I was going to get to
work on and the people I was going to
get to work with would be invaluable
experience for me to gain for later on
so when I received a promotion I took
that time not just to negotiate my cash
compensation but my total package in
this way I was able to ensure that I was
able to focus on a particular
industry and also get to work with team
members who I knew would invest in my
own development when I was hiring people
it struck me that men negotiated quite
frequently and women were not
negotiating and when they did negotiate
women would have a number in their mind
of what they wanted but they wouldn't be
able to back in to how they got that
they didn't explain to me that they did
a competitive assessment they didn't tie
it to the results and goals that I was
hiring them for and why based on their
experience they were a perfect fit and
they were going to meet those goals for
me and therefore they wanted a package
that would include X they needed to come
in prepared and just persuade me that
they could meet my needs I've been on
both sides of the negotiation first
running compensation for a large
organization and now as I place people
in jobs and where I've seen women be
most successful is when they frame their
ask in terms of how it reaches the
business goals so go ask just always
keep in mind how does it help the
company as well what I've noticed before
is candidates negotiate their
compensation package is that sometimes
the negotiation process can get so
heated and both parties can get so
focused on what they're looking to get
out of it that the candidates enthusiasm
and hunger for the job can get lost
therefore remember when you enter this
process that you want your future
employer and your boss to know that
you're not only excited about the
opportunity but you're hungry to get in
there and start the job let's start with
baby steps don't start off with a
negotiation where there's a big
relationship risk rather start a
negotiation where the relationship is
possibly not even important where
there's less risk to you to experiment
to try let me give you an example
think about going to a department store
and I don't know about you but I am a
shoe a holic I love shoes unfortunately
with my job I spend a lot of time in
boring black pumps but sometimes when I
go to shoe sales there are shoes that
sing to me you can't wear them you can't
even walk very far and I'm but when you
put them on you're like I am good so I
go to this department store
it's the sale they have a sale like once
every six months I'm there when the
store opens and I find the boring pairs
of black pumps that I'm gonna have to
buy and then there's a shoe that from
the rack was singing to me and I found
him and they were in my size it was
great
I was excited but down to the price SiC
these were really expensive shoes and
they hadn't discounted them very much
for the sale and I said to the guy I
said I'm gonna buy these shoes here
these are beautiful I want them but
they're too expensive can you help me
and he said no problem ma'am here's what
you do
buy all four pairs but don't wear these
shoes and then bring them back in a week
you return them we discounted 50% and
then you can come and buy them back
immediately
and I said it's an hour and a half each
way from my home to the store it's not
gonna happen have you got any other
options and he said let me go talk to my
manager but when he came back he said
we'll take $75 off those shoes for you
and I said that works thank you now
here's your assignment go to your
favorite department store find something
you want and then negotiate for it
figure out how to solve the problem
here's what I want it's too expensive
for me and ask for help initiate the
negotiation not all of you will be
successful
every time but you will be surprised at
how often you are when I first learned
about this research it helped me
understand why women sometimes don't ask
there is a social risk women are judged
differently and with Maggie's work it
gives us tools to negotiate successfully
in a way that works for everyone
Malcolm Gladwell suggests that you need
10,000 hours of practice to become
expert in anything negotiation is the
same way you need to practice but you
need to learn from what you experience
you need to see social situations as an
opportunity to create value so that you
and your counterparts can get more of
what you want